[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute zeige ich euch
meine kiki spezial pizza immer wenn ich
pizza backen dann gibt es auf jeden fall
diese pizza und ich freue mich endlich
zeigen zu dürfen
ich hoffe sehr dass wir auch im
geschmack trifft der unterschied beginnt
hier schon bei der sauce für meine hose
benötigen wir ein esslöffel mehl 200
milliliter gemüsebrühe zwei esslöffel
butter einen halben teelöffel kurkuma
und zwei esslöffel sahne
dafür machen wir zuallererst eine
mehlschwitze ich habe mein herz schon
eingeschaltet schmelze da die butter
allerdings lebt ihr hier nicht die
höchste temperatur stufe nehmen denn
dann brennt euch die butter ganz schnell
an
danach gebe ich das mädchen zu und lasse
das ganz leicht anschwitzen
[Musik]
nachdem diese kleinen bläschen
entstanden sind geben wir einen schuss
der gemüsebrühe hin zu früheren ständig
mit unserem schneebesen und dank immer
wieder stückchenweise mit hinzugeben bis
ihr die ganze gemüsebrühe im topf habt
[Musik]
anschließend noch kurkuma mithin zu
geben damit das auch eine schöne gelb
farbe erhält und danach kann nur noch
die sahne mit hinten damit die soße auch
schon fertig
[Musik]
die gebe ich jetzt an die seite und wir
machen weiter mit unserem ersten belag
bei mir muss es immer hähnchen wurf auf
der pizza sein und deshalb habe ich hier
in mundgerechte stücke geschnittene
hähnchenbrustfilets außerdem noch ein
wenig öl und speisestärke zum ummanteln
der hin zum bruce willis sowie salz und
versorgt die zubereitung ist ziemlich
unkompliziert begeben einfach fleisch
und speisestärke salz und pfeffer in
eine schüssel und verrühren dass gruppen
miteinander
danach wird das öl in der pfanne
erhitzen und das fleisch wird mit
hinzugegeben und schön kross angebraten
zu beginn kleben die fleischtöpfe ein
wenig aneinander wegen der speisestärke
das ist ganz normal und das legt sich
auch später wieder
[Musik]
sobald sie dann innen und außen schönen
goldbraun sind könnten sich auf der
pfanne rausnehmen
für den zweiten belag habe ich hier
kartoffeln das in drei kartoffeln die
ich in kleine stückchen geschnitten habe
außerdem ganz klein wenig olivenöl und
an gewürzen benötigen wir jede süßes
paprikapulver pfeffer salz und curry die
gewürze gebe ich jetzt direkt auf die
kartoffeln und genauso auch das olivenöl
und dann wird das ganze kurz miteinander
verrührt das gute ist dass die kartoffel
nicht vor gebacken werden müssen gehen
wir einfach ruhe mit auf die pizza
hier ist alles was wir benötigen ich
habe hier die spezialsuche unsere
bereiteten kartoffeln außerdem ein
dritten belag brokkoli das einfach ganz
normaler profi ungerührt dann habe ich
hier die fleischstückchen und lecks in
gouda käse das grundsätze für meinen
pizzateig habe ich euch bereits in einem
separaten video abgefilmt damit das
video auch nicht unnötig lang geht und
ihr seht ihr wie schön aufgegangen mehr
ist und wie schnell dann nehme ich ihnen
auf der schüssel und knete noch einmal
ganz kurz durch
ja
da ich ein blech pizza machen möchte
rolle ich den teig jetzt nicht rund
sondern eckig damit die seiten schön
gerade sind klappe ich sie immer wieder
schön ein und wolle dann noch mal
[Musik]
sobald ihr dann die größte eures fläche
erreicht habt überträgt ihr dann den
teig auf das blech und danach gebe ich
zu allererst von unserer soße drauf im
abgekühlten zustand wird die soße ein
wenig fester und man kann sie dadurch
auch viel besser verstreichen
[Musik]
den geriebenen käse mache ich immer am
liebsten auf die soße und nicht erst
ganz zum schluss so wie man es ganz oft
sieht denn dann finde ich sieht man
immer viel mehr vom belag und den käse
hat man ja sowieso drin ob man ihn jetzt
drauf macht oder später ist dann
eigentlich völlig egal
[Musik]
nun verteile ich die vorbereiteten
hähnchenbrustfilets da drauf und die
bleiben auch nach dem backen noch schön
kurz
[Musik]
als nächstes verteile ich die kartoffeln
die werden während des backofens noch
gar
[Musik]
nicht nur geschmacklich sondern auch
optisch passen jetzt noch froh kuli
mithin so genau so mache ich das immer
wenn ich pizza backen das sind genau die
drei belege die in meinen augen perfekt
miteinander harmonieren und auch der
brokkoli wird nach dem backen gar
gebacken wird die pizza jetzt bei 200
grad ober und unterhitze 6 35 bis 40
minuten
es gibt ja auch immer diejenigen die den
teig ein wenig afrika und amerikanischer
mögen und genauso habe ich jetzt diese
pizza gemacht in zeigt ein wenig dicker
gelassen und dann genauso belegt ließ es
mit der ersten pizza auch gemacht hat
[Musik]
und so sieht die fertige kiki schicken
spezial pizza dann aus und ich würde
euch am liebsten allen ein stück geben
damit ihr euch mal vom geschmack
überzeugen könnt aber verliert leider
nicht wünschte ihr wird lässt alle zu
hause mal ausprobieren damit ihr seht
wie toll das zusammenschlägt und zeigt
euch das video gefallen hat dann lassen
wir doch gern ein abo da damit keines
meiner videos mehr verpasst bis zum
nächsten mal auf die tiefs kitchen